die neueste entwicklung der kogit 19
pfalz haben die macht mir und die macht
uns allen im robert-koch-institut große
sorgen
ein chef geologe mit dringende botschaft
bitte haltet überall die korona regeln
ein
ein neubeginn mit vielen fragen nach den
schulferien soll es trotz corona im
regelbetrieb losgehen doch leere
befürchten ein chaos und ein airport im
härtetest der hauptstadtflughafen ber
läuft auf probe neun jahre nach dem
geplanten start
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg genannt und willkommen
zum nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
dienstag norbert lehmann ist auch dabei
für den sport als 100 opfer mio
das robert koch institut schlägt alarm
deutschlandweit steigen die korona
zahlen wieder deutlicher und zwar längst
nicht nur wegen reiserückkehrern sondern
der größere teil der betroffenen strecke
sich in deutschland an und zwar wegen
nachlässigkeit weil sich viele nicht
mehr an hygiene und abstandsregeln
halten
das sind die aktuellen zahlen der
johns-hopkins-universität danach haben
sich im schnitt der vergangenen sieben
tage täglich 540 menschen mit dem virus
angesteckt seit tagen liegt dieser wert
um 5 100 und ist damit so hoch wie seit
wochen nicht nach bonn sagt berichtet
die zahl der infizierten in deutschland
steigt nicht dramatisch aber doch
kontinuierlich das ruft jetzt auch das
robert-koch-institut auf den plan
die experten sind alarmiert die neueste
entwicklung der kogit 19 fallzahlen die
macht mir und die macht uns allen im
robert-koch-institut große sorgen obwohl
wir so niedrig waren sehen wir jetzt für
den anstieg und der anstieg hängt ja nur
damit zusammen dass wir nachlässig
geworden sind klar ist urlauber die aus
risikogebieten zurückkehren müssen sich
künftig testen lassen
das rkw listet insgesamt 140 länder auf
mit luxemburg auch eins der eu im
gegensatz zu anderen will der
gesundheitsminister
dass die tests für die reisenden
kostenfrei sind
dass das testen niemals eine kostenfrage
für den einzelnen werden darf auch keine
soziale frage werden dann einige
versuchen das testen zu vermeiden sich
nicht testen zu lassen weil das was
kostet davon haben wir alle nichts
bilder vom bulgarischen goldstrand
abstand halten masken tragen fehlanzeige
aber nicht nur im urlaub wird das virus
offenbar verdrängt sondern auch bei uns
partystimmung auf eine hamburger szene
meile am letzten wochenende tatsächlich
steckt sich der größere teil in
deutschland an
es handelt sich um fall anstiege in ganz
ganz vielen unterschiedlichen kommunen
und gemeinden und was wir mitkriegen was
uns berichtet wird sind familienfeiern
hochzeiten treffen mit freunden
das sind aber auch ausbrüche am
arbeitsplatz in
gemeinschaftsunterkünften auch in
gemeinschaftseinrichtungen und das
jüngste beispiel für heimische
infektionsherde in schwäbisch gmünd
infizierten sich 50 teilnehmer einer
trauerfeier in dieser moschee
ich weiß auch natürlich dass die
vergangenen monate ihnen allen viel
opfer lang kamen und wie alle wünschte
ich dass die pandemie vorbei wäre
aber meine damen und herren sie ist
nicht vorbei wir sind mittendrin in
dieser pandemie der dringende appell des
robert-koch-instituts alle müssten sich
an die sogenannten aha regeln halten das
heißt abstand wahren auf hygiene achten
und alltags masken tragen die meisten
neuinfektionen gibt es derzeit im
bayerischen mamming dort hatten sich auf
einem gemüsehof 174 erntehelfer
infiziert jetzt stufen immer mehr
bundesländer die region als risikogebiet
ein heißt die menschen von dort dürfen
nur noch eingeschränkt verreisen
vor ort wird weiter massiv getestet wie
jürgen bäumen berichtet der andrang ist
ungebrochen seit dem frühen morgen
einige bundesländer haben jetzt
reisebeschränkungen für urlauber aus dem
gesamten landkreis dingolfing-landau
erlassen
probleme auch innerhalb bayerns wir
haben auch in bayern von campingplätzen
schon die rückmeldung dass sie aus
dingolfing landau keine urlauber keine
besucher aufnehmen wenn sie nicht an
negativen corolla test dabei haben die
von uns befragten gelassen trotz
erheblicher wartezeit keine panik viele
wollen aber wissen ob sie schon
infizierte sind wird zum testen lassen
findet es nur fair gegenüber anderen
kunden mitarbeiter findet es nur fair
das ja zum testen gehe und ich hoffe
dass willy andré hanhoff mich das wenn
dessen wie kann mein alter und im hammer
geschäft der gemüsehof weiter unter
quarantäne
aber außerhalb des hofes waren von 400
vorliegenden corona tests bisher alle
negativ erleichterung aber keine
entwarnung die bayerische
gesundheitsministerin optimistisch
bisher scheint es auf diesem hof
abgrenzbar zu sein
aber da müssen wir jetzt eben auch die
ergebnisse noch weiter abwarten morgen
kommt unterstützung von der bundeswehr
ein sanitäts bataillon wird ein test
zählt in landau aufbauen damit noch
schneller ergebnisse vorliegen
wir haben dort den großen vorteil dass
die bundeswehr auch ein eigenes labor
betreibt sie auch die auswertungen uns
liefern können und dies entlastet und
der landrat rechnet in der urlaubszeit
mit zehntausenden die sich in der region
testen lassen wollen
ganz wichtig ist auch was nach den
ferien in den schulen passiert in
mecklenburg vorpommern geht schon
kommende woche wieder los die
kultusminister wollen regelbetrieb
lehrer und elternverbände befürchten
aber ein chaos so wie vor den ferien
wochen lang waren die schulen
geschlossen eltern und kinder mussten
homeschooling lernen wie es jetzt
weitergeht für 8,3 millionen schüler und
fast 800.000 lehrer anja kinos und bernd
mosebach berichten noch fünf tage ferien
dann kommen sie zurück die 1200
schülerinnen und schüler der
christophorusschule der hausmeister
sorgt dafür dass die abstände
eingehalten werden einzeln
jahrgangsstufen werden hier in größeren
gruppen zusammengefasst sollen sich
nicht begegnen so dass jetzt jene
konzept der schulleitung klassen
möglichst unter sich bleiben
in der regel werden alle schüler den
ganzen unterrichtstag in der klasse in
einem raum verbringen dort werden sie
von lehrern besucht und dementsprechend
unterrichtet sie werden also nicht in
den chemieraum gehen sie werden nicht in
den
musikraum gehen haben also immer
unterrichtung einem ort mecklenburg
vorpommern macht den anfang und sieht
sich gut gerüstet wir haben die
niedrigste infektionsrate in ganz
deutschland wir liegen damit wirklich am
besten in ganz deutschland und ich halte
es für absolut notwendig dass wir den
kindern und den schülerinnen und
schülern in mecklenburg-vorpommern
wieder die möglichkeit der bildung geben
regelbetrieb mit besonderen regeln kaum
umzusetzen sagt der lehrerverband und
waren zudem vor einer zweiten welle
es spricht viel dafür dass eine art
zweite welle kommen wird wir haben sehr
viele rückkehrer auch aus der disco
reisegebieten auch viele schüler mit
migrationshintergrund die in der türkei
waren in russland waren in balkanstaaten
waren deswegen ist nicht auszuschließen
dass wir wieder von einer reihe von
schulschließungen betroffen sein werden
die rund 13.000 lehrkräfte im land
können sich übrigens freiwillig testen
lassen
hygiene regeln müssen eingehalten werden
einer masken pflicht allerdings gibt es
nicht das schuljahr kann beginnen
der nordosten geht als erster an den
start
die hoffnung auf eine rückkehr zur
normalität das ist vor allem die
hoffnung bald einen impfstoff zur
verfügung zu haben
die mainzer firma biotec und ihr
amerikanischer partner preise haben nun
mit dem entscheidenden tests für ihre
mittel begonnen
sollten diese erfolgreich sein will bei
und tag bereits im oktober die zulassung
beantragen
weltweit werden damit nun schon fünf
potenzielle impfstoffe abschließend
getestet
alarmierende infektionszahlen in teilen
spaniens nach großbritannien zieht jetzt
auch die bundesregierung konsequenzen
und gibt reise und sicherheitshinweise
betroffen sind die regionen navara
aragon und katalonien mit der costa
brava das auswärtige amt rät so wörtlich
von nicht notwendigen touristischen
reisen ab und ein blick zu unseren
belgischen nachbarn zeigt was auch
hierzulande drohen könnte
die korona zahlen in belgien steigen
gerade so schnell dass die regierung
jetzt die beschränkungen wieder
verschafft hat glück war berichtet die
jüngsten corona zahlen in bregenz
hafenstadt sind erschreckend im großraum
antwerpen wurden in der letzten woche
911 neuer infektionen registriert eine
steigerung um 500 prozent im vergleich
zur vorwoche und mehr als die hälfte
aller neuen fälle in ganz belgien die
regierung in brüssel beschloss
angesichts dieser entwicklung gestern
strengere maßnahmen für das ganze land
statt bisher 15 dürfen jetzt nur noch
höchstens fünf personen engeren kontakt
haben veranstaltungen in geschlossenen
räumen werden auf 100 personen
beschränkt wegen des auslaufens der
epidemie müssen diese regeln strikt
eingehalten
für den hotspot antwerpen verfügten die
behörden zusätzliche schärfere maßnahmen
eine nächtliche ausgangssperre
sperrstunde für restaurants 23 uhr
einkaufen darf man nur allein home
offices pflicht und ebenso masken
pflicht auf öffentlichen plätzen auch
für radfahrer antwerpens bürgermeister
schloss weitere einschränkungen nicht
aus die zahlen werden noch steigen da
die neuen maßnahmen frühestens in zwei
wochen wirkung zeigen
die stadt brüssel verfügte dass die
beliebte kirmes am südbahnhof die am
wochenende hätte öffnen sollen nicht
stattfinden darf das ist ein schwerer
verlust für uns seit november wäre das
die erste kirmes gewesen wo wir wieder
einnahmen gehabt hätten
von einem lok downlight ist die rede
viele belgier fürchten aber eine weitere
verschlimmerung der lage in europa sind
in diesem frühjahr 160.000 mehr menschen
gestorben als in der vergleichszeit in
den jahren zuvor in der zdf- heute
empfinden sie eine andere nyse dieses
corona effects und alle statistiken zur
über sterblichkeit im detail krone hat
in den ärmsten regionen der welt
besonders drastische folgen die uno
warnt weltweit sind millionen kinder von
hunger bedroht mehr als 10.000 kinder
könnten monatlich daran sterben so
schätzungen landwirtschaftliche höfe
würden von märkten abgeschnitten
lebensmittel und medizin lieferung
erreichten viele dörfer nicht mehr
us-präsident will den pensionierten
offizieren douglas mcgregor als neuen
botschafter nach deutschland schicken er
war längere zeit hier stationiert
allerdings muss mcgregor noch vom senat
bestätigt werden
er gilt als deutschland kritiker und
fordert wie präsident trump dass die
bundesrepublik mehr für die nato zahlt
der veteran und berater tritt immer
wieder als politischer experte beim
konservativen tv sender fox news auf die
eichentür der synagoge von halle ist
berühmt geworden weil sie ein attentat
verhinderte vor fast zehn monaten am 9
oktober hier zu den schüssen eines
rechtsextremisten stand und rettete 52
gläubigen das leben oder wurde die
schwer beschädigte tür ausgetauscht sie
soll kernstück eines mahnmals werden
die neue eingangstür es wieder aus
eichenholz gebaut vom selben
tischlermeister für ihn sei bis heute
unvorstellbar was gewesen wäre wenn
seine tür nicht gehalten hätte
der täter hatte nach seinem
gescheiterten angriff zwei menschen
erschossen
mehr home office weniger verkehr das hat
die luft in deutschen städten zuletzt
verbessert aber auch schon im
vergangenen jahr war der ausstoß von
stickstoffdioxid zurückgegangen
nur noch an 20 prozent der messstationen
wurde der grenzwert überschritten
im jahr davor waren es noch 42 prozent
ein erfolg den auch die deutsche
umwelthilfe für sich verbucht ihre
klagen seien erfolgreich gewesen
beispiel darmstadt um eine klage der
deutschen umwelthilfe abzuwenden bauen
stadt und land hier den öffentlichen
nahverkehr massiv aus und modernisieren
die busflotte dazu ein weitgehendes
tempolimit die luft dort seither
deutlich rainer mit unseren klagen haben
wir eine intensive beschäftigung der
politik mit der notwendigkeit der
luftreinhaltung und in den städten eine
stärkung von bahn bus und fahrradverkehr
durchgesetzt die höchste
feinstaubbelastung wird aktuell in
münchen gemessen landshuter allee
dreckiger ist es nirgends selbst am
stuttgarter neckartor werden dann
fahrverbot nach langem rechtsstreit
inzwischen die grenzwerte meist
eingehalten
doch bis zu echten verkehrswende ist es
noch weit natürlich brauchen wir die
transformation zu tatsächlichen
klimaneutralen antreten aber wir
brauchen auch eine änderung im
mobilitätsverhalten also sozusagen die
die beste fahrt ist die idee moment
fahrrad macht in der stadt noch aber
dominieren fahrzeuge mit
verbrennungsmotor das straßenbild auch
relativ neue oft mit erheblich
schlechteren abgaswerten als erlaubt die
umwelthilfe fordert entschädigung oder
nachrüstung auf kosten der hersteller
über 10 millionen betrugs diesel die
nach wie vor mit abschalt einrichtungen
und nicht funktionierende abgasreinigung
selbst der bei der abgasstufe euro 6
die grenzwerte um teilweise den faktor
30 überschreiten
hinzu kommt wer heute ein auto bestellt
muss meist bis nächstes jahr darauf
warten
die umstellung wird dauern
auch das eine entlastung für die umwelt
das wird weniger geflogen wegen corona
und ausgerechnet jetzt soll der neue
hauptstadtflughafen ber an den start
gehen
ursprünglich geplant war das mal im
oktober 2011 neun jahre viele pannen und
mehrere milliarden euro später soll es
nun am 31 oktober wirklich so weit sein
vorausgesetzt der flughafen besteht den
derzeitigen probelauf mit freiwilligen
test passagieren jetzt schneider knapp
400 komparsen sind zum testen gekommen
seit knapp einem monat wird am flughafen
ber geprobt zum neunten mal mit
freiwilligen passagieren
ich fliege das wird vom flughafen
gestellt richtige kleidung
die komparsen müssen verschiedene
aufgaben erledigen im vordergrund stehen
einchecken gepäckbeförderung sicherheit
teilweise verbunden mit kleinen zu
setzen
das habe ich noch nicht gesehen stand
auch das jetzt meine große auswahl für
den heutigen tag
was uns auffällt einige passagiere haben
probleme mit der beschilderung finden
ihren weg nicht sofort rolltreppen
aufzüge und toiletten könnten größer
sein
im juni free bereich mit den geschäften
wird noch gebaut wie auf fast jedem
flughafen gibt es lange wege aber keine
laufbänder die das bequemer machen
durch die vielen probeläufe gibt es
ständig neue erkenntnisse
wir lernen beim sperr gepäck dinge die
nicht gezündet haben wo wir sozusagen
davon angepasst haben eine prozessen
wir haben auch gelernt wir mit großen
mengen umgeht also gerade das benennen
dass schlangen management wie kann man
größere menschenansammlungen wo die
regierung dafür in dem gebäude sind
vernünftig bewegen
beim testlauf heute gibt es insgesamt
keine großen probleme
aus sicht des flughafens fast
bedauernswert denn die verantwortlichen
sagen je mehr fehler jetzt desto besser
denn die kann man bis zur eröffnung
beheben
jetzt der sport norbert jürgen klopp hat
mal wieder
und das ist auch wirklich eine ganz
besondere ehre die noch keinem deutschen
auf der insel zuteil wurde
seine englischen trainer kollegen haben
den liverpool meistermacher zum team
manager des jahres gewählt
da ist er ein weiterer pokal für jürgen
klopp und natürlich für liverpool der
identifikationsgrad ist schließlich groß
und trophäen gab es in den vergangenen
zwei jahren reichlich champions league
weltpokal der premier league titel und
jetzt dies alex ferguson trophy eine
besondere saison endet mit einer
speziellen auszeichnung speziell auf
weil er vergessen die manchester united
trainerlegende bewundert und vergesslich
das erste treffen
ich werde mich immer daran erinnern es
war in diesem moment so als wenn ich den
papst getroffen hätte beeindruckend auch
die zahlen ferguson hat mit 13 premier
league titeln 12 mehr als klopp aber der
ist immerhin schon der fünfte beatle
wenn auch nicht offiziell unter welchen
bedingungen dürfen zuschauer wieder in
die stadien
die deutsche fußball liga will nächste
woche mit den vereinen ein einheitliches
vorgehen beschließen geplant sind unter
anderem ein stehplatz und alkoholverbot
bis ende oktober und keine gästefans bis
jahresende bundesligastart ist ja am 18
september große ambitionen hat hertha
bsc die berliner heute mit dem ersten
mannschaftstraining
es ist wieder beginnt von besseren
zeiten nach dem fast-abstieg der
vergangenen saison kann hat er jetzt
ganz andere ziele in angriff nehmen
bei der verteilung der sogenannten
fernsehgelder liegt der hauptstadtclub
im mittelfeld mit einnahmen von 59 2 9
millionen
doch hertha hat noch andere geldquellen
investor lars windhaus stockt seine
anteile auf insgesamt 374 millionen auf
um aus harter einen big city club zu
machen
es geht überhaupt gar keinen grund warum
hertha bsc ist nicht schaffen soll in
den nächsten jahren in führender
position in deutschland und europa
mitzuspielen
gut möglich also dass 24 millionen mann
tucson nicht mehr lange der
rekordtransfer von hertha bsc bleiben
wird man freut sich immer noch dass
jürgen klopp mit zweitem namen norbert
heise
ach die kleinen freuden des alltags wir
haben noch das wetter da drohen am abend
teils schwere gewitter am alpenrand an
der donau und im bayerischen wald sonst
freundlich mit etwas regen an der küste
die details hat gleich katja oliver
klaus kleber begrüßt er um viertel vor
zehn im heute-journal wir danken für ihr
interesse
wünschen ihnen noch einen schönen abend
und sind morgen wieder da sensibel auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
den abend meine damen und herren hier
sehen sie die kaltfront von tief dana
die zieht langsam weiter in richtung
südosten und bevor sie den südosten
bayerns erreicht haben sich zum teil
kräftige gewitter entwickelt das ging
zunächst in der schweiz los dann aber
zogen diese gewitter über den boden sie
weiter in richtung donau und jetzt am
nachmittag waren heftige gewitter dabei
zum teil mit grossen hagelkörner von 2
34 zentimeter größe und hier sehen sie
ganz schön wo diese gewitter hergekommen
sind eben aus der schweiz zogen sie über
den bodensee weiter in richtung
ingolstadt und regensburg und mit so
heftigen gewittern mit hagel platzregen
und sturmböen zum teil sogar orkanartige
böen haben wir auch noch in der ersten
nachthälfte zu tun
sonst ist es häufig klar und an der
nordsee gibt es einige regenschauer die
temperaturen in dieser nacht sinken
meist auf 15 bis 8 grad milder bleibt
die nach dem südosten mit 17 oder 18
grad genau dort hier im südosten da kann
es morgen vormittag noch ein paar
regenschauer geben sonst strahlt die
sonne in süddeutschland eben norden sind
die wolken dichter und an der küste gibt
durchaus schauer und da bleibt dann auch
kühl mit nur so 17 bis 21 grad sonst
geht es bis 29 grad drauf und sehr heiß
wird es dann am freitag mit bis zu 39
grad schon anders